I do but jewel in the bathroom I do own
in my car a jewel on the subway I do on
my bedroom I jewel when I'm reading the
only place I really can take a shower
i jus all the time if you don't know
what the jewel is it's a thumb drive
looking device it's an electronic
cigarette packin a high dosage of
nicotine I smoked cigarettes before
switching to the jewel but what scares
me is a lot of people who never smoked
before picking up the jewel thing and
it's not dangerous I wanted to
understand the impacts of nicotine
addiction so I talked to a psychiatrist
my name is dr. Sarver tasks friend I'm a
child adolescent psychiatrist at the
child mind Institute
so I started smoking when I was 14 years
old started smoking because one of my
friends I remember she had a pack of
smokes I'm not sure exactly where she
got them because she was young too I
started small gonna drool about a year
ago I was out of the bars of my friends
one of them had a jewel I hid it I was
like hey it was instantaneous
like I was hooked right away and I do go
through a pot and a half maybe two and
they say a pot is about the equivalent
of a pack of cigarettes so that means if
I'm eating the jewel 213 times in a day
that I am smoking a pack - a pack and a
half of cigarettes a day which is insane
so the brain is tricked into thinking
that it has done something that's
rewarding and it's our natural brain
response to go for that reward so that's
why it's very addicting and that's why
when you don't hit the jewel your brain
constantly sends that feedback get it
get it get it again in order to feel
that way again what I noticed with with
the jewel in comparison to traditional
smoking is that a cigarette you've got
this cigarette you smoke kind of a
continuous thing when chronically used
nicotine causes actually a decrease in
concentration and you will go for
nicotine in order to get yourself to the
same level so I can't focus
anxious stress it definitely has
and having some sort of negative impact
on me I am ready to quit what can we
expect to the from when we quit the
jewel the moment you stop in about you
know two hours or so you're gonna start
having cravings all I want is a pull of
that jewel to help calm me down but I
can't have it the you know the second or
the third day is the hardest after today
hopefully things will start to become a
little bit easier but then you're gonna
you know get through that hurdle long as
you feel a little bit better grades feel
a little bit better like you got this
and over time you're gonna feel
definitely better good morning
how're you feeling I feel ready same
first I'm gonna drop this in my cat's
poop box I'm gonna go for a run can't
even finish my full run cuz my legs hurt
so much I can't breathe going to a lot
of them a little bit then I'm gonna keep
myself distracted yesterday when I was
trying to read on the couch the cravings
really bad so I got out of the house to
distract myself I think I'll probably
also like go for a walk try to speak out
well are you ready to do this take one
last ride together we're done I would
say that things have gone very well for
a first day obviously it's not nearly as
terrible as I thought it would be
I'm definitely eating and craving a lot
but I'm funny ways liking bad the crazy
I toss them in yo lot this morning so
not having it has given me a huge sense
of relief but at the same time it's
giving me a lot of anxieties I keep
reaching for my pocket to grab my jewel
and it's not there so this is very
ingrained in my subconscious in my
routine day one it's the morning at the
second day my brain woke me up at 5:00
a.m. cuz I was like yo dude where's that
nicotine so I'm just
on this damn chopstick the first thing I
did when I woke up and opened my eyes
was I reached for the jewel and then I
realized so bright I don't have it
anymore I just kept having cravings when
I was reading at home so on your evil
library I can't even read you they keep
falling asleep they like I have a lot
more energy yesterday I was just
completely exhausted all day long and I
couldn't really understand why I had
slept fine the night before when I drink
that makes you want to smoke a lot more
and I didn't want to shelter myself from
the situation so today went over to my
friends house the alcohol is flowing
jewels are pulling people are getting in
a continuous legend right it's really
tempting but I am getting away from the
jewel I really stopped taking that much
of little powers just yeah I just don't
want to do it stay free of the quitting
the jewel challenge um I'm feeling very
good right now I feel like I don't need
it at all at this point so I've gotten
into the habit of smoking my jewel in
the movies but just dumb and you should
not do it I'm a great knees are pretty
bad I brought my chopstick babies don't
last super long so it's easy to fight it
and get over side effects like I coughed
a little bit but not that much tonight
but this is so weird they're really
stresses we gonna really want to but I
might push through the cravings but I'm
still peeing frequently it's like my
body is just like so weird I drool in
the bathroom until my brain is
associated that when I use a bathroom I
get that hit of nicotine I get that
reward and I getting that pleasure and
so my brain is like hey I'm gonna make
you me to pee so we can get that
nicotine and am i right in assuming that
the jewel has played an impact in my
frequent urination or do you think
that's not related think of memory as
snapshots
right whenever you're reminded of jewel
then you're also reminded of bathroom in
the sensation of urinating but it's a
psychological response that you crave
and your memory retrieves that those
hashtags yeah and then you find yourself
in the bathroom
wow these you're very happy
now if exams and papers that are doing
things like that
so I know that's usually when my level
of stress really through the roof but I
do not think that I am going to revert
to baby I think that I found healthier
coping mechanisms for stress such as
walking on day four and a-five I had to
13 hours shoot days and at the end of
the long day all that I wanted was a
pool of that jewel and that hidden
nicotine's so I need to find a new
coping mechanism whether that's running
or that's meditating or yoga I need to
find something I'm saving money because
the pods are not cheap especially for
someone who saved as regularly as I did
people say that it's a it's a vapor and
I hear you saying it's a vapor it's
actually not a vapor it's an aerosol and
the difference is a vapor is just
basically water right Oh an aerosol is
you have little tiny particles in it and
in these electronic cigarettes do have
too many particles in it they have you
know various different compounds which
are linked to you know carcinogenic
material in the end you're doing
yourself some good by not putting on
garbage you know your body your lungs
and hailing it and stuff like that all
that nasty stuff since quitting the
jewel I've noticed that I'm a lot less
anxious that I'm a lot less stressed my
focus at work is a lot better and I find
that I enjoy my time with my friends a
lot more because I'm not thinking about
when I can run away to get a hit of the
jewel you know get a stand strong and
you have to stay positive it's gonna
suck you know you're probably gonna go
through different ranges of motion
stress and whatever cravings I'm sorry
you know maybe might have some side
effects from quitting but just know that
it's all worthwhile
because there is a light at the end of
the tunnel we were both really terrified
and really didn't
know what to expect going into this
challenge but we did it can I say you
know 100 percent thousand percent that
I'll never they again or I'll never
smoke again honestly I can't say no but
my hope is that I don't I don't plan on
it and don't intend to
[Music]
you